we have the story from Insider new video
shows Roger Stone warning Trump will get
his brains beaten if he runs for
president again so here's here's here's
what I see let me see if I where do I
have this tweet okay that's not it where
did I put the tweet jump scare do I not
have it okay oh it's right here this is
literally right here what is that jump
scare uh so here's a tweet from
Christopher goldbranson it says footage
from January 20th 2021. Stone supports
impeaching Trump run again and you'll
get your effing brains beaten what you
can notice right here is I as I froze
actually let me just play the actually I
don't know if I can play the video
because he swears a lot yeah a lot a lot
a lot but in the video and then it also
makes a threat you notice you can't see
his mouth his hand is covering his mouth
and he's saying like I'm gonna come out
in support of impeachment I saw this
video on Twitter I didn't know about the
greater context but I noticed it looked
really weird and then I noticed let me
let me see if I can zoom in I noticed
something when I was watching it take a
look at this as I play it slowly look at
his mouth
you can't really see it can you and then
we get to this point near the end and
just wait for it
and there it is and uh boom right there
his mouth is gone
I understand video artifacting it
happens but when I watched this video
without any context I saw that and it
looked really strange to me because
nothing else but his mouth artifacted
nothing else it's perfectly just on his
mouth nothing else usually you get
artifacting it's not going to be so
specific now you can argue it's just a
low quality grainy video but I saw that
and I was just like where did his mouth
go why does his mouth just outright
disappear right there like what about
the footage makes it just vanish
typically when you like like I mentioned
artifacting doesn't isolate on a
specific location when everything else
is moving in the scene Roger Stone later
claimed it was a deep fake
and he's had another deep fake video
conflating my statements about Biden
with Trump I don't know any of that I
don't know who Christopher gold Branston
is and why I should believe he is a
journalist of credibility or Merit right
well this footage was actually provided
to the January 6th panel and uh where's
his mouth Roger is saying that it's a
deep fake but this was allegedly after
uh Donald Trump told Roger Stone that
he's not going to get a pardon and Roger
Stone allegedly blamed Ivanka Trump and
Jared Kushner for this and when we look
at Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner they
did represent more of the establishment
wing of his political Administration
um and you know this this doesn't look
good whether it's fake or real Roger
Roger Stone says it's fake
um I don't know I'm not an expert on
this particular you know aspect but when
you look at the basic story you know it
kind of adds up is it real is it not I
don't know look at this just just look
at this like that doesn't look real why
if he's going to say a word does his
mouth vanish for no reason like that and
the fact that even when his mouth is
moving his hand is covering it almost
the entire time exactly like how
convenient that's very weird and my
mind's kind of blown because when you
showed me this before you went what's
the next frame just go back and forth
between I did look yeah his mouth is
there as part of the shot then it just
just disappears and then you get that
it looks weird look at that right there
anyway we came back version of this no
this is the version this is this is the
version that went has got the million
views maybe it's real maybe I'm just you
know weird but look right there see how
his mouth doesn't line up with his cheek
yeah I don't know man maybe I'm just
making fun of Roger Stone for being ugly
maybe it's a real video you know what I
mean yeah the ugly doesn't make your
mouth disappear and you could maybe
argue it's just low low resolution
footage and it's an artifact but look
man I edit videos all day every day for
only the mouth disappear in that one
frame watch the frame from from this
Frame to the next the only thing that
artifacts is the mouth
I just think that's very weird and I
think that is a deep fake it's kind of
scary because Insider here is reporting
it as facts yeah I'll tell you this if
watching this and trying to be
factual to the best of my abilities my
response is I don't know however if I
was working privately as someone who's
been editing video for I'm going on 24
or five years I've been working in uh
digital video editing since I was like
12 years old I was editing videos
working flash animations designing
websites and things like that if someone
privately came to me and said this video
real I'd say my opinion would be no
right as someone who's trying to report
facts I have no idea like if I can't
give you a definitive statement I would
just say I don't know but my personal my
professional opinion having worked with
video I have uh I have friends who do
composite manipulation we do some of
this stuff for cast castle with the
weird effects this to me looks like they
manipulated his mouth or he could be a
lizard person that's shape-shifting
right now right in the frame of this
video I'm joking right I just want to
make sure it's clear it's entirely
possible it's legitimate real footage
and Roger Stone is just trying to weasel
out but I have a few questions if that's
the case why would Roger Stone be
embarrassed about something he willfully
set in front of a camera crew that he
invited to be in front of him right yeah
this isn't an undercover video they're
doing a [ __ ] right I mean they're with
him the whole time why would he now go
oh no they recorded me when I chose for
them to be there in front of me
recording me when I grabbed my phone and
said everything
I just don't it just the whole thing
well I'm performing for a camera right
well it could be when he just got the
news he got overly emotional maybe I
don't know uh but I'm not just Playing
devil's advocate here it could be a
number of possibilities it would it
would be good if we get like a video
expert to look at the video and the
codec and to see exactly what it came
from who could get a raw video sample
and then go from there look at his mouth
look at his mouth we can't believe
anything or anybody look how his mouth
like it could just be bad video like
I'll say all right weird look at that
though like you see on the top of his
lip right there are the side of his lip
curls up you see kind of those darker
pixels around the corner right there
that doesn't look normal at all no not
at all your lips don't move like that
like
yeah it's too weird his mouth isn't
moving with his face in this Frame like
look when I watched this video before I
knew anything about it I thought it
looked really weird because you can't
see his mouth and when you can it
behaves strangely then I saw a new story
I think it was the hill or something and
I was like what and they were and then
they're like Roger Stone climbs the Deep
fake and I was just like
yeah that's weird well if it's a deep
fake it's a pretty scary precedent being
said that they can just report it as
facts and they deal with their
ramifications afterwards people are also
saying look at the ear in the comments
right now and some people are saying
it's a low bit rate yeah it could be a
little bit right I mean to be honest I
don't wanna what about the ear what's
the ear doing I don't know I'm just
hearing a whole bunch of people in the
chat room look at the ear look at the
ear look at the ear oh did it kind of
jump his ear or something I mean he's
got a phone pressed up against it in a
car that's moving what's strange to me
is the way his mouth moves and the way
his mouth is covered I find that like
his mouth disappears in this Frame yeah
there's one other frame you went through
that we didn't talk about where like the
mouth like connects to the background it
was really weird where I think you might
want a little past it now
I just thought right there
that looks weird
yeah it to me the list isn't too
unnatural I think it would be really
funny if it turns out the video is
totally legit we're just making fun of
him right
yeah that is a possibility here like
when I saw this what looks strange to me
is this looks like it's an anime
character's face in this in this shot
because for those that have watched
anime you'll know that they draw the
head and then the mouth is separate so
you'll see lips but the mouth moving and
the lips are like so this I don't know
you know hey look maybe we're just
making fun of Roger Stone for being ugly
okay maybe that's it maybe that's all it
is I have no idea who's to say all I
know is if someone came to me
and asked me if I thought it was
authentic I would immediately isolate
the part where his mouth disappears and
says this doesn't look doesn't look
right
you know it's it's the problem with with
video it's a lot easier to check audio
because with audio you can see where
breaks happen in the in like the the
spectral analysis and things like that
with video you have the video and people
can easily be like it's Granny low-res
okay well why did he post a granular res
he certainly filmed this in 4k didn't he
yes but he chose he chose to post the
artifacted 480 version seriously why
serious question why is his hand
covering his mouth the whole time why
did Roger Stone agree to be interviewed
and say all these things but then deny
he said them
and why did they post the low res
version oh look I don't know who
Christopher golden Branson is and I
think if you blindly trust him then I
got a bridge to sell you but it could be
legit
for all I know I don't know man
yeah what do you think you think Roger
Stone actually turned on Trump and
Ivanka and Jared and all that or do you
think we got a dark future ahead of us
where no name people you've never heard
of can post these things not risk their
reputation and that's why they do it
yeah I think that is the future right
I'm seeing more and more all the time
like even on my Instagram Discovery page
it'll be a video of like a celebrity and
it looks so real and you click it and
it's clearly not you know so it's
getting better and better which is
pretty terrifying well he didn't get a
second pardon Kodak Black did yeah but
not Roger Stone so
right so maybe he's really really mad
could be potentially he's saying that he
was talking about Biden
I know journalists do that
they'll they they look man people they
ask like should I do the interview with
you know this mainstream company I'm
like no
because they'll say something like this
um what's your least favorite food
what's your least favorite food like
makes you sick
I I I'm really put on the spot I like
the food from last night that I hated
the restaurant it was the sauerkraut
sauerkraut I'm like you need to eat more
of this yes
how does it how would you describe the
taste of sauerkraut ugh well it was like
sour but it was also like slimy it was
just nasty cold and then what they'll do
is they'll ask a different question and
edit that question in front of your
response Temple is nasty slimy cold yeah
yeah they'll be like how do you feel
about Trump oh it's just nasty and slimy
yeah cold and then you'll be like I but
I always asked a different question and
they'll say all we did was play a video
of what you actually said right yeah we
didn't we didn't take it you know now
that's an extreme example but I have
seen what happened yep yeah they play
dirty games they'll they'll take two
different quotes from you and put them
together yep side by side and then say
no no those are real quotes well here's
how you do it in print journalism you
put a comma he said comma in between
exactly so it's just so you know I was
sitting with Blair white I say 10 more
sentences and then whatever I say at the
end exactly take out the sentences put
in comma he said and then you could
that's a trick that's a legal way to get
around it in journalism that's how
that's how slimy people do it you could
say something like you know uh did you
vote for Trump did you vote for Trump
yes so uh tell me about why you voted
for Trump
uh I felt like I was stuck in a rock in
a hard place between him and Hillary
Blair then went on to say that she felt
sick slimy and cold
and that's and that's not that it's
legal six slimy a cold taste in her
mouth yep exactly yeah that she
experienced and the best part is they
can even choose not to quote you if the
quote isn't perfect they'll say Blair
then went to then went on to express
extreme disgust over a taste in her
mouth yeah because what would have been
like sauerkraut's nasty they'll just and
it's and it's true and they get away
with it and sometimes they don't even
bother like trying to lie very well
because there was a Sun article that
covered one of my videos talking about
fat positivity and the headline was like
woman says she hates fat people and I
never said that in the video I'm like
how can you even say says something I
didn't say yeah because it's an opinion
oh yeah that's the amazing thing is if
you soon be like I never said those
words they'll be like when we said says
we meant implied through through action
and words we didn't say verbatim we
didn't put quotes on it and you they get
away with it I had a news Outlet combine
two different quotes that were 10
minutes apart to make a false oh yeah
and then when they got when that when
the subject threatened to sue him they
corrected the article saying I there was
an error in my quote as if to imply I'm
the one who made a mistake
do that to me as well the Southern
Poverty Law Center they took a quote
from the beginning of my speech and then
brought another one all the way at the
end to make me sound like I was calling
for a violent revolution when I was
calling for an evolution when it comes
to people being responsible for
themselves and smart they cut all that
out it just made me sound like a violent
lunatic on their Hit List which was
absolutely disingenuous unfair and you
know illegal in many instances and they
were sued by other people successfully
uh and had to retract a lot of that
stuff they deleted their their
falsehoods on me but I made sure every
conversation I had with them I recorded
it and they were just blanket-faced that
doesn't work though people say like if
you do the interview record it no even
if you record it they're going to be
able to lie about you and your recording
proves nothing because you don't reach
Their audience of your audience very
fine people's right exactly perfect
example of this you can listen to Trump
saying and I'm not talking about the
white supremacists and the neo-nazis
because they should be condemned totally
and even though if you watch the raw
video you know he he did not say these
things the media gets away with it yeah
and you're right you only reach your
audience it's like you can have a huge
following and still got lied about and
that's the narrative forever you know
because it's not your audience they say
sometimes like try and control as much
of it as you can and so my advice is if
you're if you're an expert in media
relations and
um and you have media training then you
should do the interviews and make sure
you phrase everything as perfectly as
possible to make it so they cannot do
anything typically what I'll do when I
respond to journalists is I give them
very specific legal language I know what
I'm saying how I'm saying it I'll break
words apart from other words so that
they so
simply put
I will give a very precise legal
response very very very precise that if
they attempt to misconstrue I could
argue actual malice that's that's that's
the thing you do but if you don't know
how to get how to actually phrase things
without them manipulating you then
they're going to do it they're going to
say like I said Blair then expressed
this extreme Taste of disgust in her
mouth you know as we as we went on
carrying the conversation and that's
true so you have to make sure you line
everything up very very perfectly so
that if they say that you can then
respond with they have the email from me
where I explicitly laid these points out
and thus it was actual malice when they
presented that false you know narrative
even if it's their opinion if it's very
clearly in you know the opposite of what
you're saying it's it's difficult to do
but I do weird things where I answer
questions with like very strange
sentences that will convey the idea but
don't speak well
so you'll notice um
if you watch the last show with Ian he
was reading a quote from someone from
Biden I think yeah it was a quote about
from Biden about Obama and he said
he said uh Biden said it's great that we
have Barack Obama and this is Biden
saying it that he's very articulate and
this is again Biden saying it and that
Obama is the first clean again Biden
saying it African-American Biden said
that doing something like that so that
they can't quote you without including
all of that or putting a bunch of
ellipses you just make it very very
difficult for them to try and
misconstrue it is that's like a
rudimentary way to try and they'll but
if you answer something like that they
usually will just don't even bother
trying to incorporate what you said
because it's too difficult to do but you
answer the question and then they can't
lie about it thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there